[Musique]
ceci est sans doute la plus grande
discothèque au monde en tout 45 mille
chansons disponibles sur internet en
quelques années la technologie mp3
révolutionner la consommation musicale
un simple clic de souris pour rechercher
son titre favori un autre pour le
télécharger quelques minutes plus tard
le fichier dans l'ordinateur il ne reste
qu'à le graver sur un disque résultat un
cd qu'il n'aura pas coûté un centime à
l'internaute et le problème est bien là
le système mp3 flirte souvent avec la
légalité la plupart du temps les
internautes téléchargent leur musique à
partir de sites pirates qui ne reversent
aucun droit d'auteur l'industrie du
disque affirme avoir perdu un milliard
et demi de francs l'année dernière avec
l'arrivée du mp3
on croyait donc la survie du cdh est
menacée par la musique en ligne on
s'était peut être trompé un sondage fait
apparaître que les français qui récupère
de la musique sur le net tu achète
autant de disques qu'avant la menace
n'est donc pas encore si grande
d'autant que le phénomène reste limitée
seuls 22% des internautes téléchargent
de la musique aujourd'hui mais il
devrait être de plus en plus nombreux
dans les années à venir le monde de
l'édition musicale va devoir rapidement
composer avec ces nouvelles technologies
un pop up homme qu'est ce que vous pour
essayer de trouver
film tient peut-être van helsing un film
qui est sorti il ya peu de temps allez
hop eh ben voilà
j'ai trop hâtivement version différente
du film van helsing 12 1927 personnes
qui l'ont 476 qu'ils ont entièrement
que je double clic et je commençais à le
télécharger
bah le partage comment ça se passe c'est
au début il ya là des versions qui sont
sur des ordinateurs qui ont même
logiciel que moi
et
plus il ya de gens qui ont cette version
la plus simple finalement l'ordinateur
photo ap ap la séquence ah oui c'est
clair c'est le logiciel qui cherchent de
lui-même quoi moi j'ai juste à l'union
de ce que je veux marie à 27 ans elle
est employée elle gagne un salaire
correct elle pourrait se permettre
d'acheter des disques des dvd et des
jeux vidéo mais il y a un an elle a pris
une connexion internet haut débit depuis
son ordinateur tourne en permanence sauf
la nuit elle ne se considère pas comme
une pirate pour 30 euros par mois
internet lui permet simplement d'accéder
gratuitement à ce qu'elles hésitent à
acheter ou à ce qu'elles jugent hors de
prix à partir du moment où
c'est de la musique que je regardais je
l'achète en cd mais quand on voit le
prix d'un jeu vidéo on télécharge non la
téléchirurgie un jeu qui est sorti ya
pas longtemps qui donc coût de 60 euros
café on a joué 20 ans décide à prendre
avait terminé donc 20 heures de jeu pour
60 euros c'est très cher je me sens
moins dans l'urgence à congrès en stop
je viens et internet ça sert aussi à ce
à quoi ça sert à partager plein de
choses et et avoir une communauté de de
partager des idées qui sont pas
forcément commercial et c'est aussi ça
le but d'y croiser allons-y partageons
ensemble faisons des choses ensemble en
compagnie de marie nous nous sommes
rendus dans une grande enseigne de vente
de matériels pour l tout ici pousse les
internautes à télécharger en quelques
minutes on peut acquérir la panoplie du
téléchargeur des ordinateurs puissants
dotés de graveurs de cd et de dvd et de
multiples appareils directement à
destination du téléchargement
ça c'est des lecteurs mp3 cd
marée bleue mp3 sous forme de
téléchargement d
croyant que son ordinateur
faire de l'informatique est étrange
qu'un sursaut de trois panneaux prêtés
le chargeur
[Musique]
en grave
çà et là
je te vois
quand on évoque ces délinquants qui
téléchargent illégalement de la musique
sur internet on imagine des pirates
forcément affreux sales et méchants
incognito
insaisissable sans foi ni loi et puis
soudain on met enfin un visage sur cette
délinquance est là plus rien ne colle
les ennemis de l'industrie du disque ont
des petites têtes bien sympathique
anne-sophie 27 ans a été prise la main
dans le sac
c'était vraiment de la découverte
culturelle la curiosité quoi c'était
c'était histoire d'aller voir un peu
plus facilement qu effectivement d'aller
fouiller dans les bacs anne sophie a
gratuitement et donc illégalement
téléchargé 1200 chanson elle risque pour
cela trois cent mille euros d'amendé et
trois ans de prison ça fait cher la
chanson la perquisition avec trois
policiers dont keith et rsa s'est très
bien déroulée puisque ils ont été très
corrects et très compréhensif mais bon
ils ont quand même démonté l'ordinateur
pris le disque dur
vérifier mes déclarations comme quoi
j'avais des cd des albums originaux en
nombre
certes même si vous n'êtes pas prêt à
voir entrer le gign par la fenêtre de la
chambre de votre fils accros d'internet
télécharger gratuitement de la musique
est illégal l'industrie du disque elle a
besoin d'exemple elle veut frapper fort
faire peur à monsieur tout le monde mais
ce n'est pas parce que le bateau décédé
cool qu'il faudrait choisir de punir au
hasard les femmes et les enfants d'abord
[Musique]